it shouldn't matter what religion you
are whatever works if it works to
increase human flourishing of more
people in more places than I'm for so
joining us on today's show is Michael
Shermer Michael is the founder of
skeptic magazine he's also the author of
a couple of books which I'll introduce
in just a second I'm really excited to
talk to him but before we get to any of
that first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at stamps.com so these
days you can get practically everything
on-demand like our podcast listen
whenever you want when it's convenient
for you with stamps calm you can access
all the great services of the post
office right from your desk 24/7 when
it's convenient for you you buy your
prints official US postage for any
letter any package using your own
computer and printer and the mail
carrier picks it up you just click print
mail you don't it couldn't be easier we
use it here at the Daily wire offices I
use it at my home if I don't want to go
to the post office because I'm busy that
say well this is what stamps calm is for
and right now use promo code been guest
for this special offer it includes up to
fifty five bucks of free postage a
digital scale and a four week trial
don't wait go to stamps calm before you
do anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the home page
type in Ben guess because we have a
guest that stamps calm enter promo code
Ben guess again you get that special
deal at $55 a free postage it's just
awesome and all the services are
fantastic it's nine o'clock at night the
post office is closed
you still need stamps that's what stamps
calm is there for stamps calm enter that
promo code bed and guests for that
special deal stamps calm promo code Ben
guest okay well Michael Sherman thanks
so much for coming on the show first I
want to pump your books a little bit
because they are both fantastic these
are the two most recent you've written
more than this but these are the most
most recent the moral arc how science
and reason led humanity to our truth
justice and freedom and this one which
just came out and was favorably reviewed
in the Wall Street Journal heavens on
earth the scientific search for the
afterlife immortality and utopia and
I've really been looking forward to this
conversation Michael because I know
there's a lot that we disagree on I
think people are gonna be shocked to
find there's a lot that we actually
agree on as well Michael is probably one
of the foremost atheists in America if
not the world and obviously I wear the
funny you had so we have a lots of yeah
thanks for to stop I don't like to find
myself is by being an atheist because
that isn't anything you know being an
atheist there's no like said
doctrines that this is what we believe
in we simply just don't believe in God .
really I'm a humanist or enlightenment
humanist or secular humanist or
something like that or I'm a classical
liberal so here are the things I do
believe defining yourself by what you
don't believe I think it was Hayek who
said you know just defining yourself as
an anti-communist is not enough yeah
what are we for right so I think points
of agreement might be something like
we're in favor of reason and logic and
empiricism and things like that then we
can find some common ground perfect so
let's start with that so you call
yourself now a classical liberal can you
give me sort of the story of your your
political development I mean were you
always in line with with classical
liberalism well I went to Pepperdine
University for undergraduate I was a
member of the first graduating class of
the Malibu campus and it was a great
great experience 1970s everybody's
reading 9r an Atlas Shrugged on campus I
mean really everyone's walking around
with this doorstop of a book and it's
like oh I just can't get through the
first hundred Peggy if you get through
the first hundred pages you're in you
know of course I did and and I think the
way it works though is if the philosophy
gels with your temperament your
personality then then you're more likely
to adopt it so in my case just the way I
was raised and by genetics or whatever I
like being an individual I like autonomy
I like you know sort of taking personal
responsibility for your actions to me
it's uplifting you mean I can actually
do something about my situation yeah you
can okay I'm gonna go do that and so I
think it gelled with me in that and so
okay what is that well libertarian you
know in the 70s that was sort of Murray
Rothbard and Reason magazine was just
getting going it's like all right but as
I got older and and the libertarian
party or party and small-l libertarians
started adopt more of the fringe
elements of society it's like no sure I
want to be associated with this guy or
that movement or the people in Idaho and
you know so I sort of dancing naked with
the iron belly yeah you met yeah you get
sort of the the pornography pot-smoking
libertarians just want to move by dough
and be by myself then you get the
constitutional libertarians and all
right so I recently just said I think
I'll try a different label I'd rather
not use any labels you know but it's a
shortcut for thinking that we all use
okay classical liberalism you know focus
on the individual is the primary moral
agent that
should be our concern there you know the
human flourishing is our our moral
concern but flourishing of what you know
not not groups not tribes not races you
know races don't vote genders don't vote
and you know religions don't vote or
protect you know it's in an individual
so I start there that you know even
though there's something like an
illusion of the self I think there is a
self inside my skin inside my skull that
we can call an individual unit that can
suffered not just think we're like
Bentham said not just think and talk but
are you able to suffer and if you can
that should at least be our starting
point what can we do to reduce suffering
so the individual so there's there's a
ton of us none of this unpack because
there's a lot in that basic thesis that
philosophical thesis but before we get
to the actual unpacking of your
philosophy I want to discuss for a
second the fact that we find ourselves
in the same room because one of the
things that's been very weird obviously
is that we've now both been labeled
members of the intellectuals are by
Aaron Weinstein and Barry Weiss in the
New York Times and how did we find
ourselves on the same side of the aisle
I mean we obviously agree about a lot of
the principles that you're speaking
about but it seems to me that there's an
entire movement that's happening out
there of thinkers from a variety of
different backgrounds who suddenly have
found themselves in common cause just
because the left has become so focused
on the other well it's it's you know
this is a driving for you to just just
gone too far
you know and we know from polling data
that the the center is getting smaller
in the left and right you know two humps
are getting larger and larger
it's a bimodal curve there and you know
in the 70s and so on it you know the
centrist was pretty large and now you
know it's it's getting smaller so I
think the further that you know each
side goes the more of us who are sort of
on these two sides want to join together
and I think that's what something like
this intellectual dark with by the way I
thought that watch should be like the
official watch of the intellectual dark
web they should try that having money I
mean I'm not even sure what it is other
than those of us who think we should be
able to talk about anything without
hysteria without the tears without safe
spaces microaggressions all that stuff
because it's the only way we can find
out what the truth is if we've gone off
the rails
you know every one of us is subject to
all those cognitive biases we're
familiar with the only way to know is
for us to talk you know and so I put
thesis or an idea and you go hang on
trim burn and and that's not quite right
and then I can adjust and come back in a
little bit if you don't talk to anybody
outside of your tribe then then then
then you you can go down the rails to
craziness and that's just not good so I
think that's what unites us and
obviously what you've spent an awful lot
of time in your life doing is talking
about reason and science when your
monthly columnist for Scientific
American you're approaching the world
record for monthly columns at one of
these major scientific publications so
let's let's go back to the philosophy
now so you're talking about human
individualism in human individual
thriving where does where do you get the
basis for this as the basis of human
society the human individual because
that's obviously a rather newfangled
concept in in Western thought as far as
the Enlightenment it's not so where is
it that yeah I've always believed that
human meaning has to come in the
interaction between individual value and
also communal purpose that if you feel
like you're by yourself all the time you
feel isolated people need other people
and people want to feel like they're
part of something broader and that
sometimes manifests in really ugly ways
how do we get to the point where the
individual is the is the key components
of morality so for me I just go back to
Genesis and then I say individuals made
in the image of God but for you because
you're not a Bible believer where does
that come from to me it really begins
for the modern world in the Wrights
revolutions of the 18th century just the
idea that there are individuals who can
have rights now the idea that these are
inalienable rights they're self-evident
well that's not terribly satisfying now
because self-evident for you may not be
self-evident for me so we have to have
some kind of argument I began with with
evolution that is we are evolved
organisms who as individuals desire to
be to gather as many resources as we can
so I start with Dawkins Selfish Gene now
don't read this by the title by self as
she just means the genes are just
perfectly on them statuary and now it
could be that the most selfish thing I
could do is hoard all the resources and
kill you if you if you try to compete
with me but living in a we're a social
species so living in a group I can't be
that way
oftentimes the most selfish thing I can
do is to be nice with you or form a
coalition with you or you and I practice
reciprocal altruism I'll scratch your
back you scratch my back and so in this
case you I think we've
the moral sense of caring about other
people now it's not enough for me to
fake being a good person like I really
care about you been you and I are good
friends but the moment we walk out I
tell my buddy yet that bastard he said
you're gonna know at some point because
we're fine tuned to reputations what
other people think about us and what
these other people are really like so
we're looking for cues like this Shermer
genuine when he says he's my friend or
is he just saying that and he's using me
and we're pretty good at discerning that
not perfect so there's always going to
be maybe 10% freeloaders bullies Free
Riders people that are just going to use
the system these are the psychopathy
sociopaths and so on the bullies of a
society and we know from research like
Christopher bums research of
hunter-gatherer groups today it's like
that it's like maybe five to ten percent
are people that don't play nice by the
rules and all these hunter-gatherer
groups have a whole series of sanctions
against the individuals who are not you
know cooperating anything from we gossip
about you we sit you down and have a
little talk with you we slap you around
a little bit or they hit back to
practice capital punishment they go out
and on a hunt on the weekend with you
know aaaghh and they come back without a
grin this is true for children too if
you look at the experiments I mean you
know this stuff better than I do but if
you do the experiments with children and
even adults they will seek to punish
each other and forego pleasure in order
to punish you if they feel like people
are violating the reciprocal rules
that's right in these common goods games
where we all put some money in the pot
if we with transparency we know who put
what in those who are cheating the
system are holding a little bit back the
I will sacrifice some of my profit just
to punish you so we do have an evolved
sense of right and wrong
I think we're born with it you know Paul
blooms research with the little puppets
in his developmental psych lab and you
know there's the good puppet that helps
the other puppet hit the ball up the and
the nasty puppet that pushes the ball
back down and these little kids that you
know they have no they don't even have
language yet you know they'll go out and
slap the bad puppet or not choose the
bad puppet reinforce the good puppet so
I think we're born with this and we have
to have it because a social group cannot
survive if everybody's too selfish so we
have to evolve a sense of right and
wrong and truly caring whatever you want
to call altruism or sympathy empathy
something I actually do care about other
people's how does that evolve
the tribe because here's this is one of
the great puzzles of human history is
number one why this perspective on the
human individual only arose in the 17th
century if this is ingrained in human
beings that the individual is a value
and that we have to work with one
another then why only in a certain place
in a certain time did it arise it was at
a spontaneous combustion of human
thought and in the 17th and 18th
centuries or was this something that has
deeper roots I obviously would argue
this has deeper roots going all the way
back to Sinai and Athens but you how
would you argue on that yeah so I think
it's it's there's a tension there always
between the individual and the group and
then how do we get beyond the small
tribes tribal size of about 150 plus or
minus right who doesn't where everybody
knows each other or related to each
other so evolutionary site can get us
all the way out to that now beyond that
we need politics economics culture
history and so on and so the one model I
use is I call this the in dugu effect so
in Jack Nicholson's movie about Schmitz
you know he's a retired insurance guy
and and he's late night watching and
there's one of these infomercials about
adopting a little kid in dugu in this
case and he gives money to a little in
dugu in the whole narrative plot is
around that he doesn't know in Dougal
from anybody but they show him the
picture of little indigo and here he is
with his soccer ball and his brother and
sister and here's their little Hut they
live in and five dollars a day will give
them so on and now if you show a picture
of 10,000 starving kids in Kenya I'm not
giving any money or I'll give a dollar
whatever you show me little in dugu so
really that's kind of tricking our brain
into making little and dugu an honorary
member of our tribe my family my friend
I care about it because and that's our
evolved brain we care about people we
know or can identify with so to get
beyond that first of all you have to get
people to care about other people by
identifying them as individuals that are
like me so that sort of principle of
interchangeable perspectives that could
be me there but for the grace of your
case God there that could be me so okay
so and so how do we do that well beyond
getting people to truly care just having
a large society with the rule of laws
and and a democracy where we at least
feel like we have some say but more
importantly I think free trade is one of
these things where as long as you and I
are both profiting from some kind of
exchange we have I've known as
to kill you and maybe I'll even start to
like you a little bit because you're
doing something for me so we know
government you know sort of liberal
democracies and free trade are these
things that provide trust in a society
among strangers such that I can go to
the Starbucks somebody waiting for me to
wait on me I don't know them they take
my money they trust me I trust them I
don't feel like I'm gonna get bumped on
the EDD or hopefully not arrested for
not paying and buying a Starbucks you
know that that the modern society is
based on this idea of trust among
strangers and that requires all these
extra add-ons so here I think of
economics and politics as tools social
technologies so my question still
remains okay I agree with a lot of your
analysis why the economics and politics
for a particular time in a particular
place is it accidental is that there no
we're just looking at a single sample
size and why is it that only in Western
Europe at a particular time at a
particular place in history do we get
this vision of individual rights that
flowers out and then starts encompassing
broader and broader groups of people
really again if this was embedded in
human capacity from the very beginning
then why does it only happen as the
outgrowth of one particular culture so
you see where I'm going
you know yep yep so well I think pker
tries to answer that and a good social
scientist that he is you know this is a
tangled web of correlations in inter
causal variables that are going up and
down and it's it's really hard to answer
I mean you get a number of things going
on you know the Industrial Revolution
free trade is coming in you know double
entry bookkeeping and all these things
that kind of drive prosperity to go up
which which enhances a bunch of other
things so we can afford better
governance and so on
then we have better educational systems
also literacy rates start to go up
everything any of this has to do with it
with the judeo-christian system that is
under grace well okay yeah so there is
yes that's part of it of course and so
just the Western idea that the
judeo-christian is you know sort of
founding helps push it along yes I know
we can go back to maybe the 13th century
or 14th century and you know the first
humanists in the 15th century long
before the Enlightenment yes okay so
there's strain i grossest is talking
about human rights back in 1530
yes yes yes right so I think there's
multiple strands when you write a book
you got to start the write somewhere so
I didn't go all the way back to Athens
in Jerusalem you know like some people
do okay so there's some threads there
but the idea that the individual is what
counts and we're going to protect the
individual's rights you know like the
Bill of Rights for example is a perfect
example of my it's not the group it's
the individual in fact these rights are
there to protect you from being
considered a member of a group that we
feel we can discriminate no you can't do
that and that those have been expanded
that moral sphere has been expanding
more and more yeah no question and I
think this is where we all end up in the
same place it's really quite fascinating
again I've had conversations with you
know you and Sam Harris and we're coming
at it from a completely different angle
as far as the impact of God in all of
this Jonah Goldberg suggests that this
is the miracle and one of my great
objections to Jonah Goldberg
terminology and that is that I'm not
sure that the miracle happened in 1650 I
think the miracle happened a lot earlier
and the bat was the enzyme the catalyst
that led to this great outpouring of
human freedom but we end up in the same
place so the question becomes how do we
argue for that because we actually do
agree on a lot of these same values even
if we think the source of those values
is different right I thought the source
of those values begins much earlier I
think that it is embedded in certain
biblical principles that are that are
evaluated and reasoned through over time
but how do we espouse those so for me I
can espouse those values in in a
particular way starting from the premise
that there's a certain absolute morality
that was established by God this is
where the God question comes in and so
I'm wondering without that absolute
morality where how do we get to that
point where we can convince people and
I'll let you answer the question but
first 60 hour work weeks traffic neck
pain back pain stress at home you are
the reason they invented the spa button
have no time to go to the spa
introducing Zeile the most trusted name
in massage and the best way to get a
same-day five-star massage in as little
as an hour because they come to you just
go to Zeile calm or use the zio app and
choose your favorite technique gender
preference time location for your
massage seven days a week 365 days a
year within an hour one of the top local
licensed pre-screened massage therapists
from zeals network of over 10,000
massage therapists can actually be at
your door with a massage table and the
music and the supplies plus for
companies who really value their teams
seal also offers on-site chair massages
for companies of any size you can try
Zeile today like today go to
you'll calm or the seal app and use
promo code Shapiro to get 20 bucks off
your first massage that's $20 off your
first massage with promo code Shapiro
Zeile spelled z ee l comm promo code
Shapiro okay so back to that really big
question that I just posed to you so you
said something about I'm gonna die what
see I don't have two feet but yeah I
mean we'll talk about that too because
obviously you have well so we'll talk
about big issues like life and death in
just a second is this your entire book
on what heaven constant on the guide
question okay like like like I just
started reading Jonah's new book the
suicide of the web which is a weird
title because it's much much more of an
uplift at least the first half is very
uplift right the meril you didn't get to
the bads at the downside well but his
first page he says there's no that the
first god oh god it's not in this book
and I'm only going to use reason to
argue for these principles perfect and
the reason that to me is good not just
because I'm an atheist but that it
shouldn't matter what religion you are
or in a sense it doesn't really matter
what the roots are although it's
intellectually interesting whatever
works if it works to increase human
flourishing of more people in more
places than I'm for it and and we should
champion those and make reasonable
arguments for why they're working and
full stop that's all we need to do so
where do you and I get our morals from
how do you know what's right or wrong I
tend to think we probably both get it
from the same place that is the still
small voice within
and then our culture our parents our
traditions and so on but where do those
come from and at some point you if you
go far back far enough you're gonna I
think argue there's a supernatural
intervention into the system that says
this is what's right or wrong but my
question would be how do you know
because we know from biblical scholars
that the Bible is something of a wiki
it's an edited volume we know people
wrote it down and he said well maybe God
inspired their writings or words or
something but if we just take something
like is killing wrong but we wouldn't
ask what is murder wrong and right as
murder by definition is wrong but
killing is what well it depends and and
so how do you know and so this is as you
know Euthyphro dilemma that is you know
if these moral principles are out there
in some kind of you know Platonic space
floating around up there are they right
or wrong because God said so or
the reasons and if we have reasons for
why it's right or what any god for right
you just skip the middleman and just go
straight for the reason so I actually
disagree with it I know I watched your
debate with interview slash debate with
Dennis Prager and on Dave Reubens show
specifically about this I'm not somebody
who disagrees that you can Intuit that
murder is wrong just without without the
presence of God in fact Judaism
basically says that Judaism essentially
says that there are certain principles
where if you were born in a wilderness
you would still be held accountable for
failing to abide by those principles and
those do include murder right so murder
is wrong whether you believe in God
whether you were born in a barn it
doesn't matter right there are certain
things you can Intuit but some of the
higher order morality that we're talking
about the value of individuals or how
far you extend the tribe I'm not sure
that that stuff can be done simply
through through pure reason I'm
skeptical of that specifically because I
think that what we tend to do in the
West is we tend to say everything that
was good was enlightened been thinking
and everything that was bad was counter
enlightenment thinking so this is my my
criticism of Steven Pinker's new book on
the Enlightenment is that what Steven
does is he writes you know a four
hundred fifty page book about the
Enlightenment and never mentions the
French Revolution right he writes a four
hundred fifty page book about the
Enlightenment and he never recognizes
that Rousseau was a member of the
Enlightenment caste he was not even
Collins on counter enlightenment that
the French Revolution was happening at
the same time as the American Revolution
essentially in the broad scheme of
things that there's a whole line of
thought including communism and Nazism
that considered itself over rational
very few actually if you actually look
back to the foundations of Marx Marx is
talking about imposing the reason of
humanity on the economic system and as a
whole so if your reason I'm not sure can
get you there is the argument that I'm
making yeah well okay first of the
French Revolution in the better angels
Steve talks about Burke and in Berkey
and conservativism and Burke was in
favor of the American Revolution against
the French Revolution why because in the
American Revolution you had a balance
between we want to overthrow the systems
that are not working but retain the ones
that are still good because those are
long hard-fought traditions that work
pretty well
now unfortunately slavery got thrown in
there but we eventually got rid of that
the French Revolution was like let's
just blow the whole thing up and start
over with including an under I remember
that but it was bent but they did
actually have a cult of reason right I
mean actually notre-dame Cathedral and
actually put an idol to
reason in the notre-dame Cathedral and
they had a cult of it so so I guess my
contention is that if you're going to
make the argument that it's self-evident
these principles eventually are
self-evident I don't think in the
absence of the the Burkean argument is
in essence a religious argument it's
there was a bunch of stuff that was
passed down to us by our forebears and
we have the capacity through reason to
evaluate whether we still think that the
evidence is on the side of particular
rules or whether these rules have been
Mis applied we have to acknowledge the
value of what has been handed down as
opposed to the tabula rasa reason which
might be mandated by the almost by the
social science approach that is now
being taken up by a lot of folks people
who might have great discussions but
whenever I read Sam Harris's books and
he says that you know throw religion out
the window and we can come up with
better than that as I said to him when I
was talking to him well you grew up five
miles from me and we share a lot of the
same principles so I'm happy to have
that discussion with you but if you've
grown up in a society that had a
different tradition I have a feeling
you'd be arguing something very
different and so what I write okay so
two things one I think
pinger makes the point that most of
these are counter Enlightenment
romanticists traditions blood and soil
of the Nazis for example that it's it's
it's the you know the race that counts
and so on that now you may make rational
arguments about that and say I'm using
reason but your reasoning is wrong and
so we can we can we can say we're both
using reason and and this these
arguments are better than those
arguments so I think those are the two
points about that I start to just anyone
and drop it but I think that the
question there about the misuse of
reason would be this is that you are
your pattern of reasoning is wrong or
that your premises are wrong because
your premises right so if your pattern
of reasoning is wrong then we can all
spot the flaw on the reasoning okay okay
here's where you went wrong or if the
premises were wrong then we're back into
my argument which is that the culture
you inherit is a deeply impactful thing
on whether you believe in individual
rights in the first place so I guess
what I'm trying to get you to yeah and
maybe I'm trying to argue into it is
acknowledging that judeo-christian
values are at the very least utilitarian
even if you don't agree with the source
of them you agree that the the legacy
that begins you know with Judaism and
through Christianity in the Christian
world that is a that is a necessary not
a contingent part of history maybe but
how do you deal with in all the bads
of the judeo-christian tradition before
the Enlightenment right you know the
Inquisition witch hunts so this is the
way that I deal with that is is what I
say is that the Bible was given to a
specific group of people if I were to
give you a written document right now
I'd have to speak the language that you
and I were speaking I couldn't use
terminology that you didn't know I
couldn't give you rules that were so
deeply radical that they would run
counter to anything you could possibly
believe so for example when Maimonides
talks about sacrifices you know these
animal sacrifices that seem really
barbaric to us now what my mom needs is
arguing in the 12th century is seee
right about a document written
presumably by Jewish tradition 2,000
years earlier he's arguing that if
you're going to try and convince people
away from sacrifice you have to first
change the nature of the sacrifice you
can't just abolish something that people
think is completely dependent and
necessary and then over the course of
time there are certain parts of the
Bible that speak to eternal human nature
right so for example this is what
Judaism Christianity would say is true
about sexual matters is that human
beings are the same regardless of where
they are they always have the same
sexual nature that is none changing but
what is changing is the necessity to
slaughter animals for example or what is
Nessa what is changing is the evidence
basis for witness testimony Yeah right
didn't do you mean like when Jefferson
said all men are created equal but he
has slaves and but by today's standards
nobody's a racist but really he's just
trying to get something done and you
can't have everything so he's saying
look we have to use what we have now and
we could try to change that later
essentially to me it feels like modern
thinkers looking back at ancient texts
saying well when Jesus said this in you
know mark 327 he really meant women
should have the vote well Wow I mean
you're getting this out of that passage
you know it's a I think we're reading
back into it a lot of it it I think that
you can you can find tradition said to
me that this principle of
interchangeable perspectives that is if
we're going to set up a society I can't
know which group I'm going to be in the
rauzein veil of ignorance and and and I
as an individual can't convince you to
treat me nice just because I'm me and
you're not me and and I have a
privileged position just because I mean
know so the golden rule is really that
and it's metallic derivatives is
as Pinker calls him and I and I like
that idea because I think that is basic
that that's the basis of that is in this
kind of evolutionary model of myself as
genes drive me to just want to hoard all
the resources but you're making the same
calculation so we have to come kind of
some agreement one way to do that is for
me to put myself in your position how
would I feel if I were been and and I
was doing this to him well okay I would
feel bad so I think religions discovered
certain eternal truths about human
nature long before there was you know
the Enlightenment or or modern Western
culture at all
I don't know how that you know maybe by
accident or just trial and error at some
point you're gonna figure out maybe well
okay well but by observation I mean it's
like that the point jordan peterson
makes about novelists having deep
insights into human nature i think
that's right and there's a whole branch
of evolutionary psych that does
evolutionary literature like when
shakespeare Jane Austen write about
their characters they're really getting
it right about how people behave their
sexual nature power structure is
hierarchy the kinds of things that drive
conflict in human relationships they
figured it out long before there was
anything even called psychology how did
they do that by observing by paying
attention so I I do think the religions
get it right a lot of the time just
because they're two thousand years of
four thousand years of observations that
get written down and then what we do is
go back and pick and choose the ones
that seem right and the other ones like
capital punishment for you know x y&z we
don't we don't practice that anymore
we've rejected those we accept these
based on what based on modern standards
like these are good arguments that we'll
use those and emphasize those to the
flock okay good that's fine okay so so I
want to talk a little bit now about the
the arguments that you make with regard
to free well because you're you're a
libertarian politically or at least
classical liberal politically you don't
want the government in anybody's
business and that presupposes a certain
level of responsibility among individual
actors because obviously you do
something and now you're responsible for
the thing that you did you have the
choice to make but you have a kind of
interesting view of free will so I am a
free will as a religious person I'm a
frugal absolutist in this
sense that I believe that I don't know
how it happens but I don't think that if
you had a giant god machine right and
the giant god machine had all the
information of the universe programmed
into it that you could predict how I'm
going to the next sentence I'm going to
say to you right right that I think that
I have the capacity is an individual
actor to there's something outside the
system in other words that allows me to
make to subsume my biology and say
something different and think something
different I'm an individual so you in
your scientific view there are a couple
things that you do that seem to cut
against libertarianism and now I just
want to know how you how you rectify the
breach so one is that you you've
suggested before that there is such a
thing as itself but they're really kind
of is not such a thing as the self that
basically are a bunch of firing synapses
that identifies as the self so without a
self and without the capacity to make a
free decision every decision you make is
determined predetermined how do you how
do you get to a libertarian political
position yeah or even just a libertarian
freewill position right the modified
version of as called compatibilism in a
survey I like to cite from 2009 of 3,500
professional philosophers and graduate
students and so on 59 percent were
called themselves compatible ist's very
fewer and the sort of pure free well
like there's a little homunculus in
there pulling the levers and the rest of
determinists say along the lines of the
arguments that sam Harris makes so Dan
Dennett is I think makes the best
arguments for these which is that first
we are we are determined I mean we live
in a determined universe there's cause
and effect this is what scientists do
when they study things except for
quantum physics which wouldn't give you
quantum uncertainty doesn't give you
free will is just uncertainty right yeah
but in other words that that position is
if there were a full god machine you
would still be you would be able to tell
me that's right yeah but but first we
can ever we're not God machines we can
never know that second we are active
agents within the causal net so you have
this constant net the universe all these
things operating but but we can actually
change the variables as we go as the
pathway unfolds we can push back we can
stop smoking we can go on a diet we can
you know and someone I want to ask you
for clarification on that but first
sorry I have to take a break for it for
Lending Club so we no need a helping
hand sometimes whether it's unexpected
repairs medical expenses credit card
debt sometimes a little money can make a
big difference and you can get it at
lending
comso Lending Club gives you access to
low rates home loans of up to 40 grand
for most any purpose take control of
your debt finance a major purchase
finally make those home improvements
it's easier than going to a bank it
offers lower rates than high interest
credit cards is a really good option
just go to Lending Club comm and enter
how much money you need and see if
you're approved in minutes and then you
can pick the offer that is right for you
the money can be in your account in just
a matter of days it's that simple for
more than 10 years Lending Club has
helped millions of people with over
thirty 1 billion dollars in loans take
charge your finances today with Lending
Club but go to Lending Club comm slash
been guest to check your rate for free
it won't impact your credit score which
is pretty cool
Lending Club comm slash been guest
because I have a guest Lending Club com
been guest all loans made by Webb bank
member FDIC Equal Housing lender so I
interrupt you right in the middle of the
stream of thought which is the worst
thing to do but where you were where you
left off was you're talking about we
have the capacity to kind of we still
have the capacity to change things we
can still go on a diet we can still so
how that's a lot of active verbs I said
it's a lot of what is a passive
phenomenal concept is that Dan Dennett
uses the degrees of freedom that is
within a mechanical system you have
degrees of freedom of how much it can
move around you know in organisms say
cockroaches have fewer degrees of
freedom than the dog the dog has fewer
degrees of freedom than the chip and the
chip far fewer than humans so and even
within human groups we the law already
takes into account the fact that say you
know murder in an act of rage or you
were on a you know you were drugged up
or or somebody held a gun to your head
or something like that we we say well
that's different than me freely choosing
well what's the difference or what's the
difference between say the oxycontin a
cotton addict and me I'm not an addict
or my father was an alcoholic for
example he just could not stop drinking
and I'm not I just didn't get the genes
okay so I have more degrees of freedom
than he had and I'm willing to cut it
say the alcoholic or the drug addict
some slack that he's not choosing like I
could choose so if I actually get drunk
and kill somebody I should be more held
more accountable than say the alcoholic
who just can't control himself although
there should be always punishment there
but anyway that's the idea that that the
more degrees of freedom you have the
fact that you can never know all the
causal variables anyway we feel like we
are free in the same way we feel we are
a self and if you want to call it a you
know Sam call
an illusion okay it's a great illusion
it's the one that makes life fun
interesting yeah I think that the the
reason that is so essentially you're
redefining free will to mean free of
outside or interior compulsion meaning
that it's not that you are free to make
any decision that you want to it's right
you are free of somebody putting a gun
to your head
or you are free of a genetic factor that
forces you to do X I'm not free to be an
NBA player okay right so there's certain
constrains
yeah we're all constrained but within
the channels that were going down
through life there they're wider than I
think most of us so intuitively think
and that you can actually tweak the
variables so there's the compatibilism
that you're talking about sounds a lot
like you agree with Sam on principle but
you agree with me in action so so the
and then this is this is what's kind of
fascinating is that you know for people
who are arguing the strong
non-compatible
position right these are people who are
arguing the strong determinist position
you end up in this weird place where you
wonder why you're doing what you're
doing all the time because but obviously
but people they don't Sam doesn't walk
around going well I wonder where he's
going what I am and he didn't really
I'll ask him again when he comes on to
me all determinists are pragmatic
compatibilist no one walks around going
well I wonder where he's going next when
I think I and I think all compatible
lists are disguised absolutist because
in the end there's what they believe is
true and they're acting completely
opposite of that because if you believed
everything was determined then you'd sit
around navel gazing all day by the way
the social science tends to demonstrate
this that when you tell kids that they
have so many constraints on them yeah
that they can't get anything done right
this is why victim ideology is really a
problem right victim victimhood
mentality you tell a bunch of kids
society's constraining you there's vague
racism out there there's vague
Institute's that are the institutions
that are trying to confirm it it kills
memories roy's them as human beings and
so learn helplessness they go well
what's the point of trying right exactly
why I think the determinist position is
not good to practice there preach
because no one that you're teaching no
one actually lives their life that way
I'm not sure you can teach childness it
is really interesting that this is you
know the the the determinist position
there's when when I was talking to Sam
and on his podcast we did a thing in San
Francisco and the best part of the
evening was a woman got up and she said
I totally agree with you Sam about
determinism but I have a seven-year-old
kid you know what do I teach my
seven-year-old that
and it was pretty amusing it was pretty
interesting because this is one of the
big questions is what do you teach your
kids if you feel that the science is not
in confluence with how they should
actually act or or move and the same
thing holds true for the self so I wanna
get your view of the self yeah we can
move further directions I just want one
more point social social psychologists
and clinical psychologists talk about
learning self control willpower and we
know now there's a lot of research on
you know the marshmallow experiment
you're right but your connection on my
daughter and then that kind of person
you can train yourself I mean just
knowing okay I know if I can resist for
15 more minutes then I'm gonna be a
better person I'm going to do it and you
can do that you can just buy so that's
an example of you actively throwing
yourself into the causal net saying I am
going to tweak the variables and you
know I'm going to I'm going to set my
alarm for 6:00 and I'm going to have my
running clothes already out because I
know if I don't then I'm less likely to
get up or whatever so just knowing that
so we're different than all the other
animals I think in the sense we're self
aware of the causal vectors influencing
us and then we can change them call it
what you want to me that's a kind of
free will or or will power use the
active verbs
I'm good with active version yeah
because that is what we do but that's a
it is but it's essentially a faith-based
argument you have faith in yourself that
you're capable of acting even though in
reality you may be just a bunch of
neurons firing based on stuff that
happened several trillion years they
probably wouldn't use the word faith but
you know we bump up I know it's not
allowed but we bump up against these
like language walls I mean this is part
of the problem with talking about God
free will in consciousness you know we
use these words and it's really hard to
define them carefully enough to get an
answer so like the consciousness one for
example this so-called hard problem of
consciousness
where what it's like what does it like
to be you been is your red the same as
my red you know oh we got to work on
this problem this is an insoluble
problem because I can never be in your
head I can't know what it's like to be a
bat Thomas Nagel is famous thought
experiment because to do that I'd have
to bolt on some wings and the muscles
and the normal modern scientists you
can't know what it's like to be a woman
and you can claim you are one but well
okay maybe if you do the surgery and the
hormones but even that's just sort of
bumping you closer and closer to that
and but but if we really did it all the
way you would just no longer be
man or a human wandering was like to be
a bet you'd just be a bat going while
I'm a bat I mean he wouldn't be thinking
right so like in Kafka's the
metamorphosis where the salesman wakes
up and he's like whatever he is a
cockroach or something yeah that can't
happen you would just be the cockroach
you wouldn't be walking around going oh
this is what it looks like to be a cut
so that to me is one of the these are
called mysterion mysteries they can
never be solved so that free will be we
use these words determining the free
will there by definition in conflict how
can you resolve them we just tried it's
not perfect and God the last one I think
if you mean by God a supernatural agent
outside of space and time well then by
definition we can never know because
we're in space it's not classifiable not
viable so if you mean like a super
advanced extraterrestrial intelligence
that we can meet one day and go oh so
you have the power to actually do even
like telekinesis or something you know
this could be done with computer chips
in the brain that's already done and so
on but that's a natural agent and I
think by god I'm never yeah we've never
talked about this but you probably mean
a super outside of space yeah the
classical definition right right so how
would you know and I and the answer is
you don't write what you don't why
you're a believer not a knower okay all
right you can I can I can know what when
I've said before is I know in God
meaning that there are certain premises
that I use for my politics and my values
in my daily life that I believe spring
from the principle that there is an
intelligent being that exists outside
space and time and that has created a
system that is knowable by us and
objective truth that is discoverable by
discoverable by us and a universe that
is understandable to a large degree by
us and that's not falsifiable but it's
it's no less falsifiable the no less
unfalsifiable than the theory of
multiple universes because we can never
get outside our universe there's no way
for us to know whether we're a bubble on
top of a bubble or whether we're
specifically designed as a unique place
for life right this is one of the
arguments that's being made now and it's
why the Stephen Hawking was so attached
to the idea of multiple universes
because there that that weird problem
that we exist which is a very
statistically
non probable event the the the way of
getting around that is by saying well
yeah we're just that series of 9s and PI
basically that when you do 100.1 before
you go far out enough you get sixty
instances of nine in a row and the
and so we say well right because pi is
sort of randomized beyond a certain
point well but there's no way to know
that because now you're positing a thing
that we cannot falsify to disperse you D
bunk
another thing we cannot falsify right
yeah where's the lever the Archimedean
lever to stand outside we can't okay now
my physicist friends tell me that the
multiverse is a derivative of their
models predicting that that would be the
case now I'm this is out of my right it
might do so I'd have to bring in but but
by keating or something so the question
is when we bump up against these these
grand mysteries what do you do with them
to me it's okay to just say you know
what I don't know you like with the with
the heavens on earth the is there an
afterlife I don't know they're like
nothing not an atheist
well in the sense that Huxley meant it
when he coined that word in 1869
unknowable I think the Godfrey will
consciousness as their phrase their
unknowable that so they're outside of
science now we can talk about them and
use reason or whatever but I think we're
gonna bump up against the wall there so
I was curious by the way that the you
know the ancient Jews said you know
Sheol and I'll you don't go anywhere
after your death yeah the idea of the
afterlife is is pretty modern invention
in Judaism it really it really only
crops up historically speaking a little
bit in the profits and it's usually the
late profits and it's and it's really
maybe as a response to early
Christianity or or Greek thought so
yeah in the Bible itself there's no
reference in the Torah there's no
reference to the afterlife
we don't think happens after the death
of your body so I mean I only have
suspicions because again unverifiable my
suspicion is that if there if there is a
God which I believe who exists outside
of time and space and that what animates
me is that I made in the image of God
and that what animates my capacity is
that I made in the image of God that I
reunify with God that basically there's
a the the traditional Jewish take on
this has been that there's a cleansing
process Judaism doesn't believe in
eternal hell
so it's instead this idea that there's a
cleansing process for your for your soul
the part that you got from God that
spark of life you got from God you
should must have schmutz it up while
you're alive and now there's a cleansing
process and then and that's what hell is
sort of and then you are reunited with
God and you have greater understanding
the idea of me being a distinct
percentage outside of my body I think is
a difficult one that's oh that's my own
personal so you don't think you're
physic
resurrected into heaven with God no I
think I think that it's something like a
soul or energy or consciousness or
something yes yes a form like an Aquinas
form right yes I think that those are
actually two different things in Judaism
as well like the idea of Tesla autumn a
theme which is the idea of resurrection
of the dead that's a different idea than
what happens after you die right Adam 18
is the idea that eventually the Messiah
comes that we'll all be resurrected back
in our physical bodies at a certain
point which you know honestly given the
nature of how science is moving and the
possibilities of cloning is it actually
less crazy than it sounded probably a
couple of thousand years ago yeah I'd
debunk most of the modern you know the
singularity is coming we're going to
upload everybody this is not gonna
happen
no definitely that's good that's good to
know because I just feel like the
computer would be really weird weird I
live inside a computer but or they were
living in the in a computer now but
there's no buffering or you know little
pixels that are going off every so often
we're investing off into space it's
because that but why here I want to push
you on something you know my Christian
friends and people that I debate
particularly on the resurrection you
know they have a whole series of
arguments you know if you just followed
our reason you would accept Jesus as
your Savior my answer to this is the
great Jewish rabbis who are smarter than
you and I sit in here they've gone
through all these arguments why why
don't they accept Jesus why don't you
accept Jesus as the Messiah okay so the
reason that I don't accept Jesus is the
Messiah is because I think that a lot of
the arguments in fit so Jesus is the
Messiah is a different figure than
anything that exists inside Judaism so
when people say that the Judaism
predicts the the coming of Christ the
the change in the nature of what Christ
is what a Messiah would be is different
from Judaism to Christianity so judaism
never posited that there would be God
come to form in physical form come to
earth in physical form and then you know
acting out in the world in in that way
Judaism posits that God is beyond space
and time occasionally he intervenes in
history but he doesn't take physical
form it's one of the key beliefs of
Judaism actually isn't in the poriyal
God so that means that it's it's a the
idea is is actually foreign to Judaism
of emerged God man who then is who is
God in physical form but then dies and
is resurrected in all this this is it's
just a different idea than existing
you're not waiting for the Messiah to
come right he's not coming and the
I'm waiting I'm waiting for the Messiah
to come in the form of a political
figure right so the pool is so that the
Messiah in in Judaism is a guy who's
gonna come back and is going to
establish peace in Israel and is going
to assure that that you know there's a
there's sort of a happier world with a
bunch of political aspects to it as
explained by Maimonides but he's gonna
die too
right he's not gonna come back and
everybody lives forever and in a
corporeal agent he's just like us right
hey and then the Jewish view any person
could be the Messiah any Jew can be the
Messiah in the Jewish right right so I
could be it who knows I'm not a good
start but that's that's a different view
than the Christian view so the argument
typically made to Jews by Christians on
this is that Jews are its forecast by
the Bible Ron and that's and for Jews we
have a whole different read when you
read the Hebrew about why this may or
may not be true Christians claim the Old
Testament predicts it's gonna come so
rights agree well I disagree because I
mean I think a lot of the a lot of these
verses that are cited actually mysteries
of the Hebrew so actually I read Hebrew
so it's so I think that but that but you
know again I that's not to disclaim the
even in the Jewish view the impact of
Christianity on world history right
that's a difference talking about the
ontological question right is there a
god out there if and is there a Jesus of
Messiah in physical flesh I have actual
beliefs that run counter to the idea of
God taking physical form as a human
being because I think that that leads to
a lot of weird yeah side effects it sure
does yeah like to my Christian friends
you know where you're resurrected in
heaven well how old am i I mean
physically resurrected yeah 30 yeah I
mean some of them say you're 30 cuz that
was Jesus was 31 you know and so but you
know but I'm 63 now so what happens to
all the memories I have of the last 33
years do they go into the brain these
are definitely puzzling questions and
this is why I don't believe in that
version but haven't read it what's
interesting we talk about this now I
mean what's interesting is is your
version of a heaven which I want to talk
about in just a second first I want to
say thanks to our sponsors over equip
the truth is most of us are brushing our
teeth wrong
not for long enough and forget to change
our brush on time that's because most
brands focus on selling flashy gimmicks
rather than better brushing but not quit
so what makes quip so different well for
starters quip is an electric toothbrush
that is a fraction of the cost of
bulkier brushes while still packing just
the right amount of vibration to help
clean your teeth quips built-in timer
helps you clean for the dentist
recommended to men
guiding pulses that remind you when to
switch sides next quip subscription
plans are for your health not just
convenience they deliver new brush heads
on a dentist recommended schedule every
three months for just five bucks
including free shipping worldwide quip
also comes with the mountain suctions
right to your mirror and unsticks to use
as a cover for hygienic travel wherever
you take your teeth finally everybody
loves quip they're on Oprah's oeis they
were named one of Times best inventions
and it's the first subscription electric
toothbrush accepted by the American
Dental Association plus they're backed
by a network of over 20,000 dentists and
hygienists and hundreds of thousands of
happy brushers use clip every single day
clip starts at just 25 bucks and if you
go to get quip comm slash been guest
because I have a guest right now you'll
get your first refill pack free with
equip electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack free at
get quip comm slash band guest that's
get quip GE tqu IP comm slash been guest
trying to remember where we work well we
believe there's a soul or something like
a soul of pattern information that
represents who you are that floats off
the body and goes continues on as I
don't know
I don't know and I don't think anybody
has a great verifiable account of that I
have suspicions but again they're
suspicions lesson less about knowledge
what I do know and the reason why I'm
religious is that a religious lifestyle
that that is based on certain
fundamental premises I think makes life
better for people I think that the rules
that are set down you know as currently
understood at least our rules that that
are likely to lead you to leading a
happier and better life then then your
pure reason alone because pure reason
alone unleashed without even those
moorings in judeo-christianity can lead
to a lot of really terrible places but I
want to ask you about your version of
heaven because we talk about heaven so
we can get back to that very
conversation just a second but you're in
your newest book is heavens on earth the
scientific search for the afterlife
immortality and utopia and you make a
pretty compelling case that heaven on
earth is basically to a certain extent
you enjoying yourself transcendentally
that basically if you go out and look at
a forest that that may be heaven on
earth or as close to it as you're going
to get not just that though that really
just living a full meaningful life and
being engaged with other people in your
society with your family and friends and
so on that this is it and we should be
doing this anyway whether there is an
afterlife or not because these are good
things to do so in the last chapter I
deal with well if it's a year
atheists if there's no afterlife maybe
there is but whether there is or not we
don't live in the afterlife we live in
this life we know that we're not we're
not living in the here and after
hereafter we're living in the here and
now if so make the most of it but not
the most of it by like just plugging in
the morphine drip alright you know
sucking down you know whisky all night
or with you know whatever whatever your
pleasures are it turns out that research
shows that that doesn't do it for most
people it's not enough I mean there are
some just pure hedonist it just you know
get stoned all day or whatever but most
people find that unsatisfying and so
there's things between happiness and
meaningfulness so leading a happy life
if this is your goal the things you do
are more short-term immediate likely
don't pain free life but you know pain
free or it's just fun like going out for
dinner with dinner and drinks the family
and friends okay that's fun three hours
later it's over it's like okay now what
but doing something that's more
long-term either in your looking back to
your past what have I done with my life
that's productive what am I going to do
in the next twenty thirty years and then
doing things that are not fun or
pleasurable now like the example I use
in the book is caretaking I've I have
four parents stepparents and bio parents
and I was caretaker for two of them and
this wasn't fun at all I had it wasn't
pleasurable driving my dad around all
these hospitals and then the nursing
homes and in the pharmacies and you know
I'd get home I just exhausted but but I
feel better as a person having done that
cuz I kind of feel like well they did
this for me when I was little and I
would want somebody to do that for me
and the cycle of life and all it you
know and and those kinds of things are
something much simpler like working out
in the morning like this morning I did a
couple hour bike ride with the guys it's
not fun when we're going really hard I
mean it's kind of painful actually but
when I'm done I'm like I feel better
about myself I did that and then down
the line it's a good thing to do that's
kind of so and this is the concept of
flow also that when you're in constant
work the happiest you are like when you
when you are one with the work that
you're doing and I totally agree with
this by the way I think that the
happiness in life is not utterly
disconnected from action in life I think
that the attempt to make a hard break
between okay so you take a bunch of
stuff that you hate during life and
you're gonna hate it your whole life and
they're gonna die and everything's gonna
get fixed in heaven I actually don't
think that's a very good way to teach
religion number one right number two I
don't know that's what religion is here
that's to do I think that thing
religion is here to better your life
here on earth and then if you believe in
an afterlife if you believe that there
is a rectification of the of the wrongs
that you experience the hands of others
you are a baby who is killed by the
Nazis and now there's an afterlife where
you're going to move on that's that's a
different question slightly than what
religion provides to most people and so
when I talk about religion that is why
I've found your book actually kind of
interesting and inspiring is that when
when I talk about religion the stuff
that I find the most interesting about
religion is not the stuff that happens
that's unfair viable after you're dead
it's the stuff that you're doing well
you're here and a lot of that is tied in
for a lot of people with religion in
fact I think that the decline of
religion in America has been heavily
tied in even from a secular point of
view with a with a decline in secular
happiness for a couple of reasons one is
obviously the lack of community right as
you fragment communally there's been
attempts to sort of graft on different
forms of community in the absence of
Church but those have largely failed and
you're seeing people atomized in a new
way because of social media that's
that's a real problem whereas you see
higher levels of communal happiness when
you feel like you're part of a group of
people who in Italy have a common
worshiper yeah so I think that we don't
have a human need for religion that's
too big a word we have a need for
community society for being part of a
social group that's doing something that
we feel is good and right and and and
gives me deeper meaning not just fun fun
fun pleasure doing something with
friends is one thing but being part of
it say a religious group a bowling
league or whatever in the famous I'll
make I'll make I'll challenge on that a
little bit in the sense that you say
that you know being part of a community
is is the entirety of it I'm not sure
that a bowling league is quite the same
thing as a church boy it's probably not
the right exhibited today but is an
interesting one because obviously Robert
Putnam uses Bowling Alone as the as the
evidence of lack of community in
American life and I would say it's
probably not going to church is the best
example of black community because it's
not just about being a member of a
community it's about feeling like you're
a member of a community with a common
purpose that is in fact transcendental
and that matters I think that when you
talk about purpose and and
meaningfulness and leaving a minute and
living a meaningful life I think there
are people who are capable of generating
self generating meaning and feeling good
about what it is that they do but I
think that human beings by and large and
this is my main case religion actually
is I think that human beings by and
large are really crappy at defining
their own meaning I think when human
beings are left to their own devices to
generate their own meaning I'm I'm
that you and I agree on politics but
people very often find meaning and
controlling others they very often find
meaning in making standards for others
they very often find meaning in making a
better world and by that they mean
silencing people they disagree with and
shutting them up in the human history is
replete with this and it's replete with
religious people who did the same thing
so the idea of a transcendental purpose
I think there is a necessity for people
people do seek the religious which is
why religion is common to literally
every culture on planet Earth so by
transcendent if you mean beyond just
ourselves yes I live or even yes so like
for me going to Mount Wilson or other
observatories where there's huge
telescopes in the big dome is just as
meaningful as when I go to the my wife's
um from Cologne Germany so we go to the
dome there it's this you know 2,000 year
old magnificent is it and I love going
in there I feel like this is a
transcendent experience in the same way
as when I go to the astronomical domes I
think it's the idea of getting us beyond
ourselves in some bigger way not not
just beyond her friends and family but
you know our whole lifetime lifespans
and so on
now the religions that do that I'm on
board with you not all of them do that
you know the prosperity gospel business
Joel Osteen these people a great ruffalo
dollar all the way back to Reverend Ike
you know God wants me to be rich and you
know animal ethat but the ones that are
going out to man the soup kitchens and
so on and helping the poor okay that's
good whatever it takes to move the
needle a little bit to reduce increase
human flourishing and reduce human
suffering and which brings me to the
question of cosmic impact so the
difference between going and looking at
the cosmos and saying wow I am a tiny
speck of humanity amidst this
magnificent thing you know that whether
it came about accidentally or create you
create it was created it's irrelevant to
this particular moment when I'm looking
at something and saying wow that's just
incredible
but does that imbue you with a sense of
purpose like how do you get up every
morning is what I'm asking it right and
some of it what what what motivates you
to get up every morning that you're
having an impact in the universe a
religious person would say I'm having an
impact because God wants me to do X
right God gave me a certain set of rules
to live by and everything that I do
matters which is why Judaism is such a
ritual based religion and really takes
ritual seriously like every time I drink
water before I do that I'm supposed to
bless God and recognize that God is
present in my life which is an attempt I
think to get to that feeling of the
but of course their religions that do
this in a bad way like certainly my
purpose is to get up this morning and
become a suicide bomber right that's
that's the wrong purpose you've got so
how do we know which is why I'm not yes
right
we don't worry there set of beliefs yeah
and so we have to have some kind of
standards what are our standards and
where do we get those okay I'm back to
the Enlightenment or you know wherever
you want to start using reason to get it
get us there so religion can do it but
not all of them do
I think it's reason and religion and I
think that's why we can have a
conversation because really so great is
that I'm not coming at it and just
citing Bible verses at you I'm saying
it's a merger of religious revelation
and a reason that takes that and crafts
it you know and then and then it's a mix
that religion is an enzyme it's a
catalyst and then in that catalyst is
what creates the cheese of civilization
right you put that enzyme in there
you're grating the cheese of
civilization you don't have that enzyme
in there that you do Christian enzyme in
there and it just remains a watery way
yeah you have to pick and choose though
from the Scriptures to get to get the
ones that we are now using to say
contribute to a better society and
ignore the other ones the well they were
picked and chosen right I mean that's
why we're here so that's it yeah I mean
the the passages in Leviticus and
Deuteronomy a lot of them are pretty
grim yeah so so we do this anyway and
you know why do I get up in the morning
well I have a family that I you don't
want to take care of I like working I
enjoy it
I like being productive I want to move
the needle a little bit make society a
little bit better through my writings or
whatever and I just you know I I think
I'm not sure I call it cosmically
I'm not sure there'd be a little
egoistic to think I can you know change
the ecology and everybody else a little
bit yeah you know just just a little bit
yeah okay you want to say you have to
move the needle to make things better I
mean we have to define better we have to
make moving the needle and and all of
this has to exist in a context where you
feel like you are making a difference
but but you don't do it because you're
expecting to get rewarded in the
afterlife no I'm doing it out of duty
and I think this is a difference between
duty and reward you know religion puts a
heavy focus on the idea that it doesn't
matter what you want to do right finding
your bliss is a lot less important than
you doing what you're supposed to do
well here I think we can derive duty
from Kant's deontology there are certain
things which really are consequential
arguments these are good rules and
duties and things we should do why
because it makes society better and I
don't think you have to step out of
this world to justify it you can justify
through pure reason now that people are
critical of cut to a certain extent on
this but but we can we can at least get
there if we bolt on some utilitarian
arguments and maybe some Rawls Ian or I
think it's possible to get there I don't
think it's mandatory to get there okay I
mean it and that's that's why I think
that the argument from pure reason tends
to fail just because pure reason in the
absence of culture ends up at the French
Revolution so here you have right so
here we want it throw empiricism okay
what are the actual consequences and
results what can we see so for example
you know we have 50 different states
with 50 different constitutions 50
different sets of tax laws 50 different
sets of gun control laws and so on we
can look around and see the different
experiments as they unfold and go well
this one's working this one's not
working so yeah like I was just there
was a news story last night about the
rates of homicides in Chicago just went
down like 50 percent because they
implemented this police program that
we're using here in LA where they put
cops out on the corner because they have
the data showing right you know there's
more homicides and gang drug things at
that corner right there go Park a squad
car there and get out of the car and
stand there okay boom you know these
things so whatever works in that sense
right the only question becomes at that
play and then we get back into the big
question so what is working constitute
because it wasn't one of my favorite
shows on TV is men on the high castle
have you seen it on Amazon it's really
it's really fun but it's fun in a in a
not in the the pure purest sense I mean
it's it's a the story of the show is
that there is the Nazis and the Japanese
won the war they beat up the country and
if you go into Nazi land everything is
beautiful the planes work beautifully
they have these it's like 1960 and they
have these incredibly advanced
technologies everything is
extraordinarily clean of course
everything everything seems wonderful
for the people who are alive for the
quartet not so much but this is this is
one of the big problems I think in in
constant ology is that when when Conte
says you know treat everybody is you
would have everybody else be treated
which is basically a rewrite of the
Golden Rule it's slightly different
right the the original Golden Rule is
actually the silver rule which is don't
treat anyone else's you would not want
to be treated right once you get to
treat everybody else's you'd want to be
treated well if you feel you're a
superior being that means you get to
treat inferior beings in an inferior way
right and so I think that we we have to
come up with some definitions that are
reliant on certain premises and that's
why I keep insisting on the on the Prem
if we can accept the same common
premises then I think that we end up at
the same place and this is why I don't
think atheists are there are people who
argue atheists can't be moral I think
that's utter nonsense but I will argue
that a system without at least certain
fundamental faith principles okay
whether they call them God based or not
we have to take certain principles on
faith in order to end up at the right
place they're not all self provable me
just saying I'm start this is my moral
starting point period I can't prove it
but this is where I'm heading yes I
think probably we do that yes I mean I'm
trying to make the argument you know
that the individual is the you know
moral starting point survival and
flourishing of sentient beings something
like that but their words you know right
just string together some words and I
try to base it you know so we're evolved
organisms so I don't think it's a proof
I think it's just a it's an argument you
you but you're calling on well I'm going
one step further outside of space and
time but but still at some point you
have to tell us how do you know what the
deity wants because again you know
Mohammed aha when he's flying the plane
in the building he's just as sure as you
are that hey the outside source told me
this is the right thing to do yeah and
the proof of that he's wrong is that
he's wrong and it's it's wonderful to
have you I really appreciate the
discussion one of the most fun things
that I get to do every week is talk with
folks like Michael Shermer folks go out
and get his books heavens on earth is
his new one and his slightly older one
but just as worthy of the read is the
moral arc how science and reason led
humanity toward truth justice and
freedom Michael thanks much for stopping
by I really appreciated
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy Boren associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens
edited by Alex zingaro' audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jess wah Oliveira and title credits by
Cynthia and gula the Ben Shapiro shows
Sunday special is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018